un couvre-feu à 18 heures mais pas de
confinement des écoles des frontières
ouvertes et une pandémie qui continue de
faire partie du quotidien des français
avec en plus l'arrivée de nouveaux
variants mais pour le gouvernement
même si le virus est toujours actif la
situation est maîtrisée et ne nécessite
pas plus de restrictions notre situation
je la qualifierais donc par deux mots
maîtrisé par rapport à ce que l'on
observe chez nos voisins mais fragile
car le virus circule encore activement
sur notre territoire est d'autant plus
fragile avec l'élément nouveau que
constitue l'émergence de nouvelles
souches plus contagieuse due à cette
situation maîtrisée les fragiles
également considéré meilleur élève que
ses voisins de l'union européenne et
malgré un recul des contaminations
berlin a décidé de prendre les devants
face à une hausse des nouveaux cas chez
certains de ses voisins
résultat les arrivées depuis la
république tchèque et le tyrol
autrichien se font au compte-gouttes un
test pcr négative doit être présentée
afin de pouvoir entrer sur le territoire
une décision qui ne va pas dans le sens
de bruxelles qui défend la libre
circulation instauré par l'espace
schengen je peux comprendre la peur face
aux mutations du coronavirus mais il
faut dire la vérité qui est que le virus
ne se laissera pas arrêté par des
frontières fermées
la seule chose qui est ce sont les
vaccins et les mesures de précaution
sanitaires
il est à mon avis erronée de revenir
comme en mars 2020 à une europe ayant
des frontières fermées
une déclaration qui ne passe pas en
allemagne d'autant plus que vers l'un
reproche à bruxelles la lenteur de la
campagne de vaccination
maintenant ça suffit la commission
européenne a commis assez d'erreurs lors
de la commande de vaccins au cours des
derniers mois hors union européenne
d'autres pays il est également choisi de
ne pas lésiner sur les restrictions
sanitaires pour endiguer la pandémie et
éviter la propagation des nouveaux
variants sur leur territoire à auckland
en nouvelle-zélande après que trois
personnes ont été dépistées positives au
codis
9 dont 2 aux variants britannique ce
lundi la mairie de la ville la plus
peuplée du pays a décidé de confiner ces
habitants pour trois jours cette méthode
de confinement rapide a également été
adoptée par l'australie la chine taïwan
ou encore le vietnam
une stratégie qui vise à réduire à zéro
la circulation du virus
de nombreux spécialistes plaident pour
qu'elle soit aussi appliquée en europe